Show yourself Jedi
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my mandalorian season 2 episode 5 video
we finally got ahsoka tano and she teased so
many other characters that are now coming to
the series eventually so we'll explain everything
there were so many easter eggs and references to
all the older stuff they even referenced some deep
cuts from the old republic so if you're new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything we'll
do a new giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and post all your favorite easter eggs from the
episode on the video careful for spoilers for
the episode if you haven't seen it yet because
we'll be talking about everything including
the stuff that they foreshadow and characters
that they mentioned during the episode that we
probably won't see until a little bit later this
season or possibly not even until future seasons
i'm going to number the video a little bit
differently as we go through easter eggs and
the episode and big plot points just because there
were so many things so this needs to be like a top
50 video when it's normally a top 10. but just
starting at the beginning of the episode the
title was the jedi so a lot of people pointed this
into like well ahsoka's not a jedi why are they
calling the episode the jedi the titles of the
episodes usually reference a number of different
things within the context of each episode so the
jedi title wasn't just meant to be a reference
to ahsoka it was meant to be a reference to grogu
whose name we got i'll talk about that in a second
too baby yoda finally has a name it was also a
reference to the jedi order and the other force
sensitive jedi out in the galaxy that survived the
purge that ahsoka talks about later in the episode
there is another make all the empire strikes
back references there were many of them during
the episode but the episode begins with an ahsoka
fight with all this panic shouting in this town
surrounding the forced planet of corvus that
mando is headed to she's running around taking
out imperials with her dual white lightsabers
from star wars rebels remember she lost her
original lightsabers the anakin skywalker gave
her back at the end of clone wars she fought
and defeated a sith inquisitor then purified his
lightsaber crystals and used those to make her
new twin white lightsabers rosario dawson looked
fantastic i wasn't sure exactly what to expect
there's been so much fan art of her as ahsoka a
lot of it was pretty close the episode was written
and directed by dave filoni who helped create the
ahsoka character with george lucas for the clone
wars and if you notice the artwork at the end of
the episode over the credits the concept art of
ahsoka for the episode is actually drawn to look
like ashley eckstein who's the voice of ahsoka on
the clone wars and rebels but they give her just
a slightly older look because she's supposed to
be in her early 40s during the events of the
mandalorian series she's actually not that old
and when you think about it her species lives to
a couple hundred years old pretty easily so she's
even younger than she actually seems but because
she's one of the most powerful force users in the
galaxy after order 66 she takes down the imperials
pretty easily at no point during the episode even
during the final boss fight did it seem like
she struggled that much we get michael baine
he's our next celebrity cameo he's just playing a
regular mercenary he's not playing a pre-existing
star wars character and they didn't give him an
actual name during the episode his character they
just refer to him as a mercenary notice the
architecture on top of the battlements here
this piece is actually just a reference to this
original ralph mcquarrie concept art from tatooine
they give ahsoka a clear setup for her i'm no jedi
line from star wars rebels it's one of the more
iconic lines that she had on that tv show when the
magistrate literally calls her a jedi she doesn't
say anything though they just kind of hold back
on that the magistrate's name is morgan ellsbeth
she's actually a brand new character that they
created for the tv show obviously the way they fit
her into the pre-existing canon means that she was
around for the imperial era of the original movies
and even back during the clone wars because they
say that she had her origin story during the clone
wars but the actress who's playing her is actually
a real life stunt woman who's worked on a bunch of
big productions so that's that they were able to
pull off that big fight scene at the end with the
best scar spear they gave you a pretty easy setup
for the episode ahsoka wants information from her
i'll talk about that in a second too because
that's one of the biggest teasers for future
plot that they dropped during the episode but the
whole idea is that the empire is just mining this
world the forest planet of core of his forest
resources just sort of strip mining it slowly
they've taken over the town and they're just
keeping the town's people hostage threatening them
if ahsoka doesn't go away mando arrives at the
planet corvus with grogu they said at the moment
with the control knob and him using the force
that they pay off later in the episode with the
jedi training montage given some of the reveals
later in the episode now it makes more sense
why they spend so much time with these father-son
type of moments hyping up the energy between them
even the armorer at the end of season one
said that mando was like his father now
i believe the giant creatures that are all walking
around in the distance behind them are brand new
that they just created for this tv show they
didn't seem familiar from any of the other
series before they have a nice gunslinger standoff
moment where mando walks up to the city gates and
meets michael baine's character they sort of
acknowledge each other as different warriors
oh you're another bounty hunter from the guild
okay you're allowed to enter when he walks through
the city they try to draw a lot of parallels to
navarro from season one episode one with werner
herzog's imperial character ruling over the city
because it's the same situation the empire came in
took over the city and now they're running things
kind of running them into the ground so to speak
like he also walks past a spit roasting a bunch
of small animals he did the same thing during
season 1 episode 1 when he walked past all the
roasting kawaki and monkey lizards the salacious
crumb animals once he makes it to the magistrate
you notice that they have a couple hk87 assassin
droids which are kind of references to knights
of the old republic in hk47 different model but
it's kind of the ig-11 twist from season 1 like
the referencing ig-88 from empire strikes back
but it's ig-11 a different model of that same type
of droid this is also one of many old republic
even knights of the old republic references during
this season so far so it's almost like jon favreau
and dave filoni are huge fans of the video games
as they should be this is the way and when mando
is talking about the a350 blaster rifles that
the guards are all holding those are actually
from rogue one he starts meeting the townspeople
who don't want to have anything to do with him the
person who talks to him that father is actually
the former governor of the settlement that was
deposed when the empire showed up so at the end of
the episode they're kind of giving him his title
back giving him back control of the city but like
i said because they're trying to make a lot of
references to the original pilot episode they make
a lot of parallels between the female magistrate
character and werner herzog's character they both
put a bounty out on a force sensitive character
it's just that during episode 1 the bounty
was for grogu and now the bounty is for ahsoka
in the prize in both cases was very valuable
best car it's just this time the best car is in
the form of a spear pure best car michael baines
mercenary character makes a joke about grogu when
mando says oh what's this oh i keep him around
for luck oh you're going to need it that's just
a reference to pretty much any of michael baines
iconic movies like think about it you have aliens
terminator k2 even tombstone all situations
where luck played a very important role them
going into impossible situations most of them
not making it out and in the case of terminator
him actually dying when he passes through all
these trees you actually notice the owl here i
think that's meant to be an easter egg for mirai
who's an owl that's connected to the daughter
of the force inside the world between worlds
that special owl that shows up during rebels
but then he heads off to find ahsoka and it
becomes mando versus ahsoka she gets the drop
on him pretty easily after he sets grogu down
nearby and starts looking at the giant creatures
in the distance they play up a lot of easter eggs
and references to the jedi mandalorian wars in
the clone wars when they're fighting you could
tell ahsoka tano is a much better fighter much
more capable than he is she sort of runs circles
around him and uses a lot of his moves against him
because she spent a lot of time with mandalorians
Bo Katan during the clone wars she knows their
tactics and like i said is still one of the most
powerful force users left in the galaxy he finally
uses his flamethrower again trusty flamethrower
he broke his streak the past few episodes during
season 1 and at least the first few episodes of
season 2 he used it in every single episode it's
like his favorite weapon then finally ahsoka
meets grogu and gives us his entire backstory
and it's way more information than i ever expected
them to give us they spend the rest of the day
into nightfall just sort of silently communicating
with each other through the force telepathically
a lot of people wondered what his name was going
to be they said that on the show they knew what
it was during season one they'd already picked
it but it was just a question of when they were
finally going to reveal it so i love the fact that
he doesn't do this verbally i know early on when
people started calling him baby yoda they wondered
if he were to speak out loud would he also have
the same backwards style speech that yoda speaks
with or would he speak like a normal person
the way they played this episode it makes it seem
like we're never going to hear him actually speak
out loud for the duration of the mandalorian
series like he'll always just communicate with
other characters telepathically through the force
ahsoka clarifies a whole bunch of details about
how he fits into the star wars canon and how smart
he is how much jedi training he's had previously
where he came from originally and what's going
on with him in the future so really big stuff
he was raised at the jedi temple on coruscant for
quite a while trained by several jedi masters over
the years he's 50 years old so a lot of jedi
masters would have come and gone in that time
meaning that he did know master yoda but i know
everyone kind of wonders is he yoda's child so
obviously this confirms that he's not a clone
he's just another member of yoda and yaddle's
species even though ahsoka says she only knew
master yoda she didn't know yaddle she only
knew one other of his kind his name was yoda the
way he explains order 66 to ahsoka is that all he
knows is that someone he doesn't say who took him
into hiding to protect him when anakin skywalker
was going around killing all the other jedi in the
temple then for some reason there's the stretch of
time where his memories go dark and he just feels
incredibly lonely alone until the mando showed
up during season one the other really cool thing
about his backstory is that he was actually born
the same year that anakin skywalker was born so
had anakin skywalker not died during return of the
jedi they'd both be in their early 50s right now
also really cool music easter egg too because star
wars music is so important when she starts talking
about master yoda they actually start playing
yoda's theme music from empire strikes back then
when she starts asking mando whether or not grogu
can still use the force she starts making some
obi-wan kenobi references she gives him the same
speech that obi-wan gave luke about the nature
of the force the force is what gives the jedi his
power she gets really sad when she starts talking
about the fall of the jedi there's a lot of
layers baked into that sadness cake because she's
talking about the fall of the jedi order at the
hands of the emperor with order 66 but she's also
referencing the time she left the jedi order by
choice because she became so disillusioned during
the clone wars then she gives grogu his big jedi
training montage test so obviously this is meant
to be a callback to yoda training luke during
empire strikes back with the levitating rocks when
she says i sense much fear in you obviously that's
a reference to yoda talking to luke before he
went into the cave much fear i sense in you
but then she makes a whole bunch of anakin
skywalker darth vader references when she
says i can't train him because he's so attached to
you i've seen what that can do to fully train jedi
knights obviously a reference to anakin skywalker
becoming darth vader so when she says she can't
train him she's just saying that she doesn't
want to create another darth vader the rise of
darth grosgu somebody's going to be writing that
fan fiction on tumblr soon the bargain he finally
makes with her though is that she'll train him if
he helps her with her empire problem and get the
information that she needs from the magistrate
the way she explains the magistrate is he was
actually just a normal person during the clone
wars whose people were killed off just twisting
her into darkness like anakin skywalker became
twisted to the dark side and became darth vader
she then went on to work for grand admiral thrawn
helping plunder worlds around the galaxy using the
riches that they gained from each of these planets
to fund the creation of the imperial star fleet
that's also a callback to the Bo Katan moff gideon
darksaber storyline i think Bo Katan also used the
word plunder when talking about what happened to
the planet mandalore during the mandalorians purge
so again it's just them tying all these different
storylines with major characters together with an
overarching storyline when they head back to
town mando makes more jokes about mandalorians
and jedi working together more callbacks
to the knights of the old republic era
then under cover of night they make their attack
ahsoka jumps the battlements pretty easily i do
like the way that they pulled off a lot of these
practical fight special effects obviously there's
a lot of cg involved in this too but you're never
quite sure what it's going to look like till you
actually see it happen and they did a really good
job with the stunts so i am happy with the overall
expression of ahsoka's character she moves like
you would expect ahsoka to move they have a couple
big gunslinger standoff moments then you have the
ahsoka versus the magistrate fight obviously the
best star steal resistant to lightsabers that's
why they set that up earlier in the episode with
mando's fight with ahsoka and her not being
able to penetrate his best gar steel armor
she finally calls out our new big bad's name
where is your master where is grand admiral thrawn
letting us know that he's going to eventually
show up in live action and mando manages to
take down michael baines character now during all
these fights obviously they rescue the prisoners
they make a couple aliens references with the way
ahsoka moves and takes out all of michael baines
men they have a bit of a michael bane tombstone
reference in their final standoff he played one
of the villain gunslingers johnny ringo in that
movie who was taken down by doc holliday in a
very similar gunslinger standoff moment that they
had during the episode but talking about some of
the larger implications for grand admiral thrawn i
did a video earlier this week just speculating on
how he might show up on the series because of some
other things that they were doing like if ahsoka's
coming back from the unknown regions it also means
that thrawn probably survived and i know a lot of
you are now asking because if thrawn is back in
the outer rim somewhere does that mean that ezra
came back with him i think it's heavily implied
that we'll see him at some point in live action
but no idea who'd be playing that character or
when he would show up we don't even know when
grand admiral thrawn himself is going to show up
on the series hopefully they'll call back to that
before the series finale but i think a lot of
that will also get into the potential ahsoka
spin-off series that they've talked about doing
but the next morning after they finish freeing
all the town's people she gives him the best scar
spear and says this belongs with a mandalorian
even though he jokes about not completing the job
i didn't kill you i didn't complete the bounty
this is also meant to be another callback to the
Bo Katan darksaber storyline with moff gideon
it belongs with a mandalorian but ahsoka does give
him a new mission to go to the ancient jedi temple
on the planet tython a lot of you who play the old
republic game probably recognize this because it's
a big location during that game and it actually
shows up in the darth bane novels but according
to the games this ancient jedi temple at tython
is supposed to be the location of the birth of
the jedi order which i know is kind of confusing
because during the last jedi they say that luke
skywalker is at the original jedi temple on ach to
so which one is the original jedi temple where was
the place where the jedi order was born i think
the best way to interpret that is that tython
is just one of the original jedi temples one of
the oldest ones in the galaxy but he's supposed
to place him on the seeing stone at the top of
the mountain which is kind of like the place
where luke skywalker was sitting at the top of the
jedi temple when he was forced projecting himself
and he'll choose his path but what he's going
to be doing though think about it this way is
sort of setting off a beacon in the force
around the entire galaxy that any force user
that's powerful enough will be able to detect and
track down now that includes good force users like
former jedi that survive the purge but it also
includes other powerful dark side force users like
sith or former inquisitors that could find him as
well it's just like setting off a giant air horn
in the force around the entire galaxy letting
everyone know where you're at so ahsoka is just
telling him that there are other jedi out there
that will eventually meet on the series obviously
there's a reference to ezra bridger but it's
also the potential for them to introduce other
characters from anywhere else in the canon that
they want so any potential jedi that survived the
purge could now show up on the series but then as
mando goes off to the planet tython in the ancient
jedi temple ahsoka goes back to her mission to
find grand admiral thrawn so the idea is there's
so many story lines that they tease during
this that are so big with so many characters
they probably will cover some of this on some
of the spin-off series but wherever they do show
up yes i do now think that we'll see live action
ezra bridger and live action sabine ren eventually
if you spotted any other big easter eggs or
references during the episode that i didn't
mention during the video just write them below
in the comments because there were so many big
teasers for upcoming characters and storylines
i'll try to do bonus videos for all them over the
next couple of days but leave all your specific
requests on the video which of those do you want
me to do first everyone click here for that new
grand admiral thrawn mandalorian video that i
posted a little while ago and click here for
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!